we all know bank savings account
interest rates are garbage but why
mortgage rates are low but still a solid
three to four percent and banks are
allowed to invest a certain portion into
the stock market which has averaged
eleven point one seven four percent over
the past ten years and a thirteen point
three four seven percent with dividends
reinvested yet the national average
savings account interest rate is just
zero point zero six percent so here's
why banks are ripping you off
first of all bangs can't actually invest
all of your money as they need to
reserve some of it for people with the
drawing a federal requirement for most
big banks is to keep at least 10 percent
of their deposits in cash meaning that
they can invest 90 percent of their
deposits however after the 2008
financial crisis banks have been very
cautious about lending out this is good
as it reduces the risk for depositors
but reducing how much is invested would
clearly reduce all file returns as well
nowadays most major banks are only
investing about 70 percent of their
funds with the biggest banks only
investing in the 60s the issue is that
the returns generated from investing
just 60 or 70 percent of funds have to
be distributed to one her personal
investors for instance let's say people
gave you $100 and you invested 60 of
these dollars even if we get an awesome
return of 10% doubt only be six dollars
which out of the hundred dollars they
gave you is only a six percent return
and you wouldn't even get to pay
yourself the standard payment across the
finance industry is 2% of the total
funds this would go towards paying all
of their buildings their employees their
advertising their apps and so on and so
forth they actually have a lot of
overhead so 2% is actually an
understandable fee back to our example
this would mean that you could only pay
back your investors $4 or a 4% yearly
return but that's still a lot higher
than what banks actually pay so where
does the rest of the money go well that
brings us into the second issue which is
their returns when you invest a few
hundred thousand or a few million or
even a few billion it's easier to get
higher returns because you simply have
more opportunities available to you for
instance let's say due to the recent
crash you think airline stocks are a
great opportunity you could invest a few
hundred thousand or a few million or
even a few billion like Warren Buffett
into the various major airlines but see
if you were chase a bank you could buy
the entire company's of Delta American
Airlines United and Southwest and you
weren't have even invested 5% offered
oil deposits
however despite the difficulties of
investing so much money large banks have
actually done really well for how much
they're investing chase averages about
4% are a wiper year and Wells Fargo
actually gets a good amount higher at
five to six percent now once again these
are very impressive for investing
hundreds of billions of dollars but
these are still much lower in the market
and definitely much much lower than the
ludicrous rates they charge for their
credit cards but even with their ROI
figures they can afford to pay out more
interest for instance with Chase
investing about 70 percent of their
deposits and getting a four percent ROI
on average this means that their overall
ROI is about 2.8 percent considering
that they have 1.3 trillion in deposits
this means their overall revenue per
year is about thirty six point four
billion dollars they actually get a lot
more because of fees and other forms of
revenue at this point they can charge
the industry standard of two percent and
easily be able to cover all of their
operating costs which would be about one
percent and they can profit the other 1
percent and still have 0.8% to pay back
depositors in other words they can have
a healthy profit margin profiting 10 to
20 billion per year even after paying
back all depositors 0.5 to 1% and that's
the largest bank in the world yet they
only offer 0.01 to 0.05 percent interest
on their savings accounts smaller banks
can actually pay out significantly more
for instance US Bancorp invested solid
80 to 85 percent of their total funds
and they more or less matched the market
with 7 to 8 percent early returns this
means that their overall or a Y is about
6 percent they can actually charge the
industry standard 2 percent and still
have 4 percent to pay out they don't
even have to pay 4 percent they could
take a 3 percent cut and still pay out a
solid 1 to 3 percent yet they to once
again only offer 0.01 percent interest
there are a few banks however who offer
decent rates like Capital One at one
point represent a lie Bank a one point
two five percent
and think Renea 1.3% so here's the
rundown banks have reserve ratios and
extraordinarily large funds which makes
it hard for them to get good overall
returns plus they also have large
overhead so that's why banks can't offer
returns of five to ten percent which
would be regular on the stock market but
even after dealing with these setbacks
and accounting for a good profit margin
the large banks can easily offer a 0.5
to 1.5 percent interest and small to
mid-size banks can offer one point five
to three percent interest yet only a few
even come close to these numbers so why
well there are two reasons for this
starting with the federal funds rate the
federal funds rate is the interest rate
that Federal Reserve charges the banks
to borrow money this rate is actually
really important and has a very complex
effect on the economy but to simplify it
just think of the Federal Reserve as a
money lender to the bank just like me
and you since the financial crisis the
federal funds rate has mostly harbored
around 0.1 to 0.2% for a few years it
grew to about a little more than 2
percent but the pandemic once again
caused it to crash to basically zero now
think about it from the bank's
perspective why would they pay me and
you 0.5% interest when they can just
borrow money from the Fed for 0.1%
interest plus the Fed isn't randomly
going to withdraw their deposits or
suddenly switch banks so savings account
interest rates will usually be under the
federal funds rate that's the first
reason the second reason is just because
they can large banks have already built
up a robust reputation and their net
deposits continuously grow year after
year despite their low interest rates so
why would they be motivated to offer
good interest rates sure their net
deposits might grow at a faster rate but
they'd still make more money by cutting
down interest rates and that's exactly
what they do as there's really not much
competition from the other banks anyways
but this isn't necessarily a bad thing
though low interest rates in savings
accounts generally motivate people to
investor
in various ways whether in the stock
market real estate or opening a business
and all of those options provide much
better returns and Bank ever could
anyways Plus bings aren't really meant
to be a place where you store away all
of your life savings instead you should
just use them as a safe place to keep an
emergency fund and save up for large
purchases but that's just what I think
do you guys hate banks comment that down
below and drop a like if you think this
video explained the limitations of
banking well and of course make sure to
subscribe to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one